[Music]
on this tuesday night russia refocuses
its war in ukraine
brutal new bombardments and bloodshed
another stage of this operation is
beginning why the battle over the
donbass region matters so much to russia
canada's housing market cools what's
behind it after prices hit the roof
cleared for takeoff no more mass
mandates for american travelers i like
seeing everybody's face the impact on
canadian passengers and a rousing anthem
against russia's invasion
the ukrainian rock star fighting back
with all he's got
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
the next phase of russia's brutal
military invasion of ukraine is underway
after suffering heavy losses and pulling
back from the capital russia's foreign
minister says the plan now is for the
complete liberation as he calls it of
the donbass in eastern ukraine ukrainian
forces are holding the line for now but
keep pleading for weapons that are
needed immediately today prime minister
justin trudeau said canada is answering
the call
in canada we'll be sending heavy
artillery to ukraine with more details
to come in the coming days
trudeau was part of a video call with
the u.s president and other world
leaders the u.s agreed to send heavy
artillery and said fighter aircraft from
other countries have also been sent
britain also pledged to send more heavy
equipment and offensive weapons canada
has already sent some defensive military
equipment and small arms and ammunition
to ukraine plus humanitarian aid but
according to the keel institute for the
world economy our contribution is
eclipsed by others the u.s leads the
world in financial humanitarian and
military aid to ukraine canada ranks
ninth after estonia and sweden the need
is clear russian troops have regrouped
and a major ground in air assault has
begun crystal commansing has our top
story on the start of what could be a
decisive battle in this war
these are the horrors of the renewed
russian offensive in ukraine while the
world watches civilians here are
confronted by it daily
he worked in security not far from here
says this harkev resident of his
neighbor every day he went to go and get
something to eat
har kiev ukraine's second city has been
bombed repeatedly in this latest round
at least four people were killed harkief
wasn't the only eastern city hit with
deadly violence the kremlin says it
struck more than one thousand military
targets monday night but civilians were
not spared
another stage of this operation is
beginning
and i'm sure this will be
a very important moment of this entire
special operation the u.s pentagon
estimates russia added 11 more battle
groups bolstering troop numbers by
roughly 8 000. russia is focusing on the
donbass region but fighting is not
limited to that
location all of eastern ukraine down to
the black sea is at risk for nearly two
months now ukrainians have been fighting
for their future early in the morning my
husband just tweaked me with the words
it began
sorry
millions have fled thousands have been
killed and then there are those who are
trapped
this
i'm here with three children she says
it's really not the place for children
to be
this video is from the azov battalion it
has far right ultra nationalist routes
its members are now fighting alongside
ukrainian soldiers in mariupol the group
requests safe passage for roughly 2 000
civilians reportedly including some
canadians it says are trapped in the
steel factory being used as a last stand
location for fighters
ukrainian officials say they want peace
but will not concede any territory so
they'll keep fighting
crystal gomanson global news
london this is the region of eastern
ukraine where russia is focusing a large
part of its assault right now called the
dawn bass it borders russia it's the
agricultural heartland of ukraine it's
largely russian speaking and has both
territorial and historical significance
vladimir putin says the donbass belongs
to russia there's a theory he wants to
take it over by may 9 russia's annual
victory day jeff semple explains why the
dawn bass matters so
much donbass region in eastern ukraine
was home to a pre-war population of
around 4 million people and major cities
such as donetsk luhansk and mariupol now
in vladimir putin's crosshairs
this businessman ran a local pizzeria
he's now fighting with ukraine's
volunteer defense force
in donbass we are a free people he says
but russia is trying to finish what it
started in 2014
indeed parts of the donbass have been at
war for eight years after russia annexed
crimea pro-russian separatists tried to
take the donbass but around two-thirds
of the eastern regions remained under
ukrainian control producing a simmering
stalemate
just days before his invasion putin
signed decrees recognizing the
separatist republics of donetsk and
luhansk and promising to rescue their
russian-speaking populations from what
he called a genocide
asked whether putin is rescuing them
this russian-speaking resident scoffs
putin should retire he says he should
rescue his own people we are ukrainian
prior to the war he worked in a steel
factory like many in the don bass it's
very much kind of a rust belt of ukraine
it's an
economically very um very important
key region the region fell on hard times
in the 1990s but remained strategically
important if russian forces captured the
donbass and her son putin could control
a land bridge across ukraine's south
coast and after the botched invasions of
kiev and other areas the donbass would
also give the russian president a much
needed victory
this is
a huge importance for russia
not to show not to look as losers uh and
also to keep um ukraine under constant
pressure and control
may the ninth marks victory day in
russia commemorating the soviet defeat
of nazi germany the kremlin reportedly
wants to declare some kind of victory in
ukraine by that date but many military
experts believe a russian victory in the
donbass will take much longer and there
may be no victory day for russia at all
jeff semple global news toronto
president putin's two adult daughters
are among the latest russians to be
sanctioned by canada they're suspected
of hiding their father's wealth a dozen
other close associates of putin are also
on the list including more oligarchs and
their families
the dream of home ownership in this
country has all but evaporated for many
people real estate activity is at an
historic high royal lepage predicts home
prices will surge 15 percent in the
fourth quarter of 2022 compared to the
same time last year mike charlay looks
at whether efforts to cool the hot
market will work is the red hot real
estate market cooling or just taking a
break the bank of canada hiking interest
rates appears to have had the desired
effect homes that were seeing 15 to 20
offers are now seeing fewer than five
before anything under 2 million was kind
of flying off the shelf
now again it's not showing well and it's
not
super appealing to the consumer it's not
getting the same amount of attention it
was even two months ago make no mistake
it's still a seller's market the number
of homes available remains historically
low coupled with high demand you can see
how the agent for this toronto semi
wrote in the listing floor is damaged
please watch your step the property is
gutted to the studs and still sold it
for a million dollars or a hundred
thousand over asking it's been a long
time since houses were considered
affordable with the last few years
showing prices on an even steeper upward
trend however the canadian real estate
association reports the average home
price fell two and a half percent in
march to 796 thousand dollars six
hundred and thirty three thousand if you
exclude the red hot vancouver and
toronto markets from the equation but
one month does not make a trend and when
compared to last year prices are still
up 11.2 percent there is a lot of like
mixed signals i guess or a lot of
different ways in which the data can be
interpreted but i would say overall it
does pain in cooling a cooling price
picture but certainly not one that's you
know what would flag a a a significant
decline in prices and this is where
policymakers have difficult decisions
ahead of them economists expect the bank
of canada to hike rates another two
percent before the end of the year and
while that should cool the market even
further it could have a detrimental
effect as well the enemy of the real
estate market is not
higher interest rates the enemy is
rapidly rising interest rates if for
some reason because of inflation
the bank of canada chooses to raise
interest rates very very quickly as the
market now is predicting that can be
more difficult on the housing market to
deal with so the choice appears to be
either lower prices or higher interest
rates or possibly a combination of both
none of which lead to a more affordable
housing market microlight global news
toronto
in the last budget the federal
government identified housing
speculation as a contributing factor to
rapidly rising home prices and it
declared a two-year ban on all foreign
investment in residential real estate
how that will be implemented is not
clear and it won't impact canadians who
are buying up property as investments as
our chief political correspondent david
aiken reports dozens of members of
parliament are among them
the post-budget message from the prime
minister was clear
when foreign investors and corporations
use housing as an asset it drives prices
higher and higher and makes homes out of
reach of the middle class
homes are to live in
to raise a family in to build a life in
not a way to boost the balance sheet
and yet dozens of his own mps have
purchased housing units not to live in
but as an investment to boost their own
balance sheet
a global news review of mp's filings
with parliament's conflict of interest
and ethics commissioner finds that at
least 65 mps from all parties including
42 members of the prime minister's
liberal caucus hold rental or investment
real estate assets there is nothing
illegal about mp zoning investment
properties so long as those investments
are disclosed to the ethics commissioner
and in fact a bank of canada study found
that investors a vast majority of them
canadian account for one-fifth of home
purchases in canada what we're cracking
down on uh is the fact that there are
foreign investors and big corporations
the buy homes
in canada
and then just let them sit housing
affordability experts though say there's
not much difference in the behavior of
foreign investors corporate investors or
real estate investment by everyday
canadians including mps and ministers
they're thinking that the
financialization of housing only happens
at this big corporate level
but what your data about the number of
investment properties held by uh cabinet
minister shows is that it also happens
more at the regular everyday person
level and that has been the key point
for gen squeeze and there could be more
mps who are landlords the post-election
disclosure statements for 91 of the
country's 338 mps are still being
processed and have not yet been
published david aiken global news ottawa
money earmarked for vulnerable canadians
coming up why critics say the prime
minister's pledge to improve long-term
care comes up short
[Music]
prime minister justin trudeau is in
northern new brunswick today promising
to improve funding for long-term care
across the country shortcomings and
staffing shortages and care facilities
are well known and as abigail beeman
reports advocates are still waiting for
long-promised national standards
the federal government will provide 22
million dollars to improve care for
residents of the province's long-term
care homes and assisted retirement
facilities while no one turns up their
nose at a cash boost even local seniors
advocates in new brunswick were
disappointed the prime minister's
announcement wasn't about long-promised
national standards of long-term care
it's progressively getting worse instead
of better sharon tier says while the
latest wave of covid may be less deadly
staffing shortages are critical and
affect care her membership lost 400
nurses over the past two years nine
percent of the workforce without
replacements she's also not happy to
learn the 22 million is a
re-announcement from two years ago and
some is already gone some of the money
was spent as as it was needed over the
past two years while the liberals last
election platform promised to legislate
national standards and invest nine
billion dollars in long-term care the
latest budget only promises one million
in future federal spending and makes no
mention of national standards
care for seniors making sure that the
dignity and the quality of life
for people of all ages across the
country is something that impacts all of
us we need accountability because
without legislative in there told that
um but i won't give up i'll tell you
that right now it's canada's national
shame and we're still sitting here
spinning our wheels asking ourselves the
same questions and dealing with the same
problems national standards are still in
the works public consultation on draft
reports just wrapped up but there has
been no more mention of a safe long-term
care act which would legislate the
process and experts say that is critical
to accountability
abigail beeman global news ottawa
taking it off ahead what the end of the
national mask mandate in the u.s means
i acknowledge the hurt
and the anger
and i said that people had a right
to expect better
of their
prime minister
and i repeat that mr speaker again
in the house now
that's british prime minister boris
johnson apologizing again after being
fined for attending a birthday party at
10 downing street during covet 19
lockdown in 2020 but he repeated that he
didn't realize he was breaking the rules
back then and he denied misleading
parliament johnson initially denied
there were any parties during lockdown
then later admitted there were at least
five others are still being investigated
by the police
in the u.s a national mass mandate is no
longer being enforced after a federal
judge in florida appointed by former
president trump struck it down saying
the cdc failed to justify it and had
exceeded its authority almost
immediately airline passengers got the
message and masks came off ross lord
explains what it means including for
canadian travelers
it was a popular mid-flight announcement
if you choose to you may remove your
mask
i like seeing everybody's face
you forget what people look like
when they announce it on the plane
everyone just cheered and ripped her
mask off
a court ruling that coveted 19
researchers say will make the divided
states of america even more vulnerable
then this federal judge out of florida
decides that she's a public health
expert and is
subverting all of it i think it's i
think it's a mistake and i think a lot
of people will get coveted unnecessarily
canadian experts agree
if no one's wearing mass anymore and
we're still in the throes of the sixth
wave that transmission will increase
simple as that in a statement to global
news transport canada says there is no
change to the current policy in canada a
policy that requires masks on all
canadian airlines at all flights leaving
or coming to this country
some canadians like the american ruling
i'm glad
ben glad i mean i don't like the mask it
fogs up my eyes and stuff so but many
other travelers say masks are still
necessary that they'd keep wearing them
even if they were no longer mandated as
long as this pandemic is still in full
swing which i believe it still is i'm
going to wear a mask until
the numbers have disappeared i'm an
immunocompromised and it wouldn't be
good so my husband is 81.
um so this is this we didn't plan on
this i would still wear a mask um yeah
if
it was the epidemiologists that are that
are suggesting it is well i would still
wear a mask this epidemiologist says
those comments do not surprise him as a
nation canadians for the most part are
more community-minded or more about
self-sacrifice for the public good not
that americans aren't but we are to a
greater degree especially around public
health
the u.s decision covers all mass transit
unless local jurisdictions impose their
own orders some airlines say staff at
the check-in counters will keep wearing
masks for now as lawmakers and medical
authorities wrestle with their next
maneuvers in a deeply divisive pandemic
ross lord global news
thousands of frustrated sun wing
passengers are stranded in airports on
their way to or home from tropical
destinations as the airline works
through what's called a network-wide
system outage the issue has led to
lengthy check-in times and boarding
delays as sun wing has to manually
process passengers only 15 of its more
than 40 scheduled flights have taken off
since monday and there's still no
timeline for when the issue will be
resolved
next sounds of ukrainian solidarity
[Applause]
[Music]
where the ukrainian people find their
strength their resolve in the face of
unrelenting russian bombardment is an
individual very personal thing but what
seems to be uniting them is music in
particular a folk song about a red berry
that's a national symbol of ukraine
eric sorenson on the power of symbols
and songs
the red kalina is a berry that
symbolizes ukrainian culture rich in
dance and music and stories
this song in the meadow a red kalina was
written in the first world war to honor
ukrainian riflemen
the lyrics echo today
a red kalina has bent down low for some
reason our glorious ukraine has been
worried so
[Music]
like many ukrainians andrei klivnyak
returned to defend his country a rock
star in the band boombox he now patrols
the streets of kiev
one day he stopped to sing about the red
kalina
[Applause]
in their troubled homeland the song is
inspiration hey hey rise up
[Music]
others like the lithuanian opera
listened were uplifted and joined in
[Music]
from the ukrainian child on a step to a
south african musician
to pink floyd
[Music]
versions of the song are now arousing
feelings and raising funds for
humanitarian aid in ukraine
the song suggests ukraine has been here
before and ukrainians once more will
raise the red kalina
that is global national for this tuesday
i'm donna friesen there are many
versions of that beautiful folk song we
leave you tonight with another one
[Music]
and she's joined by about 300
lithuanians answering her call to stand
up for ukraine the 21 year old fled
ukraine in 2014 when russia invaded
crimea her mother and brother remain
there helping defend it
thanks for watching
hope to see you here again
[Music]
remember